you'd be forgiven for forgetting about
passengers but jennifer lawrence never
will
if you can't recall passengers is a
sci-fi movie focusing on lawrence and
chris brad's characters
aurora lane and jim preston they are two
passengers among many on an interstellar
journey
and aurora and jim wake up early 90
years
too early as a matter of fact with no
obvious way to go back to sleep
when you have 90 years to kill with
someone things are likely to turn
romantic
out of sheer boredom if nothing else
however even though lawrence and pratt
have strong on-screen chemistry
the act of filming those steamy scenes
was decidedly flaccid
especially for lawrence the actress
recently opened up about the many
ways in which her experience getting
intimate with her co-star was less than
ideal
through no real fault of prats that
doesn't mean she despised filming
passengers
instead whenever she had to get all
lovey-dovey in the film
things turned awkward quickly during a
round table discussion hosted by the
hollywood reporter
jennifer lawrence revealed that
passengers had her first
intimate scene ever on film and she used
liquid courage to help her get through
lawrence said she felt extremely awkward
knowing the scenes she had to film
so to prepare for her big moment she
drank
a lot all that alcohol had unintended
consequences though
lawrence grappled with extreme anxiety
in between
shoots while lawrence knew that her job
was to kiss the then married to anna
fairest chris pratt
even the feigned infidelity gave her a
queasy feeling every time the two had
the lock lips in front of the cameras
to make matters worse the actual process
of filming romantic scenes was less than
fun
one scene that was cut from the film
required pratt and lawrence to rock a
table back and forth
and neither of them liked it when asked
about the scene lawrence said
sex scenes are the most unsexy things in
the world
i can't think of anything else to try
to save us
i don't even want to think about it
anymore the duo's on-screen romance
also led to some real world problems
when acting in a romantic movie there is
always the unspoken fear that fiction
will bleed
over into reality complicating real-life
relationships
when two stars have blazing on-screen
chemistry it is a law of the universe
that the rumor mill is going to kick
into overdrive just ask bradley cooper
and lady gaga
while many celebrities understand that
this is part of the job and can find the
mental fortitude to rise above it
this gossip almost always takes a
psychological toll
tales of behind-the-scenes infidelity
spread like wildfire
after chris pratt and his wife actress
anna faris
announced their divorce jennifer
lawrence was at the top of the list of
potential causes
due unfairly to the romantic scenes she
had filmed with pratt during passengers
lawrence shot those rumors down during
an interview with instyle
stating that the film had already been
wrapped for years by the time
ferris and pratt announced their divorce
not even on a fair spot into the rumors
in her memoir unqualified ferris states
that she was good friends with jennifer
lawrence and was embarrassed by the
gossip faris also writes that lawrence
was apologetic
about the whole thing as she knew it was
adding even more stress onto ferris
during a stressful time
while jennifer lawrence has mostly
unpleasant memories of filming
passengers romance scenes
it wasn't all bad in true jennifer
lawrence style
she liked them the most when they went
off the rails generating some of the
best moments on the film
set during an interview with lawrence
usa today
discovered that one of passengers
funniest moments was completely
unintentional in the movie
lawrence and pratt's characters
eventually don space suits and
after they take the helmets off they go
in for a kiss
but bump into each other because the
suits are so big
that wasn't supposed to happen they were
supposed to lock lips passionately but
the unforeseen
bulky nature of the spacesuits
transformed the scene
into a comedic bit everyone on set liked
it so much that it was left
in the film's final cut this unscripted
moment is yet
another entry and the list of movie
bloopers that were deemed superior to
the intended versions
coincidentally another recent example of
such a scene
also involves chris pratt that time he
accidentally dropped an
infinity stone in guardians of the
galaxy
oops check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you